[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo nous sommes ensemble
pour 30 minutes le temps de refaire le
tour de la semaine politique et
parlementaire qui a été intense n'est ce
pas nickel ou tous éléments bonjour à
tous
notre invité cette semaine pour parler
de toute cette actualité propriétaire
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député de
seine-et-marne coprésident du groupe
heller constructif évidemment on parlera
tout cela est ainsi que la réforme du
code du travail qui est examinée par
ordonnance à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat la loi pour moraliser la vie
politique provoque aussi également des
remous
le gouvernement a dévoilé sa feuille de
route fiscale pour 2018 les 1000 bruno
le maire à gérald darmanin était
auditionné puis l'actualité des
républicains bien sûr on y reviendra
largement à la fin de cette émission est
la semaine commence michael le lundi 11
juillet à l'assemblée avec le coup
d'envoi du grand chantier de l'été
c'était ce lundi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'ordre du jour le projet de loi qui
habilite le gouvernement à réformer le
code du travail par ordonnance les
députés de la france insoumise et leurs
collègues communistes ont donné de la
voix dans l'hémicycle passe d'armes et
débats animés jusque tard dans la nuit
retour sur la première séance avec
céline martel baptême du feu dans
l'hémicycle pour la ministre du travail
muriel pénicaud défend sa réforme visant
à favoriser le dialogue social
d'abord nous souhaitons que les
entreprises et les salariés décident
davantage par la négociation des règles
qui leur sont applicables venus nombreux
les députés de la france un soumises
présente une motion de rejet avant même
d'examiner le fond c'est le recours aux
ordonnances qui ne passe pas vous nous
demandez de renoncer sur un sujet majeur
à notre rôle de législateur purement et
simplement
et bien pour notre part nous vous
opposons un grand non vous n'aurez pas
notre blanc seing pour pouvoir jouer les
apprentis sorciers avec le code du
travail
ses critiques sur la méthode sont
reprises par le groupe nouvelle gauche
et les communistes déjà très irrité par
la brièveté de l'examen du texte en
commission
la ministre se défend d'éluder les
débats en commission il ya une dizaine
d'heures de débat nous aurons plus de
300 amendements à examiner les
examinerons tous nous discuterons sur
tous vers 22 heures les députés passe à
l'examen du premier article qui vise
notamment à faire primer les accords
d'entreprise sur les accords de branche
jean luc mélenchon sera lors de son
silence pour dénoncer une inversion de
la hiérarchie des normes on peut déjà
signé un accord dans une entreprise
différente du texte de la loi à la
condition qu'il soit meilleur pour les
salariés que ce que prévoit la loi
et ceci s'appelle le principe de faveur
si vous changez cette règle
si vous changez cette règle c'est pour
permettre qu'il se décide dans
l'entreprise ou dans la branche
quelque chose qui serait moins favorable
pour les salariés que ceux qui se
trouvent dans la loi critiqués pour leur
silence aux commissions accusé d'être
docile dans l'hémicycle les députés de
la république en marche finissent par
rendre les coups mes chers collègues de
la france insoumise vous n'avez pas le
monopole du peuple il est bien facile de
poser sans arrêt chefs d'entreprise et
salariés ce qui nous anime c'est la
bienveillance
c'est le respect et ça n'a pas beaucoup
transpiré dans bon nombre des changes
que nous avons entendu suspendu à une
heure du matin
les travaux reprendront aujourd'hui à 15
heures dans l'hémicycle alors donné mais
c'est qu'on entend beaucoup les élus de
la france un sou vise aussi leurs
collègues communistes et vous
constructif vous êtes tous dans ce débat
a coûté on a des députés qui sont là
depuis le début de ce débat qui sont
devant la commission des affaires
sociales et qui contribuent d'une façon
constructive et responsable au débat
vous savez je crois que on a d'ailleurs
par exemple obtenu que la ministre nous
disent que très clairement une fois les
textes d'autorisation de travail et par
ordonnance beauté et avant la
ratification des ordonnances aux
commandes la rédaction des ordonnances
les députés seront associés à cette
occasion on a été ce qui avons insisté
énormément sur sur sa dès le départ jean
christophe lagarde stéphane 2000 que
président lors de la réponse au premier
ministre pendant le débat sur le
discours de politique générale donc on
en fait un principe oui aux ordonnances
moi je considère que les ordonnances et
un moyen d'accélérer le travail
législatif et on sait bien que le temps
législatif est trop longue
oui aux échanges entre la chambre et le
sénat les deux lectures c'est trop long
il faut aller beaucoup mérite meilhanais
mais le mais c'est que il faut associer
certes les partenaires sociaux mais
aussi les parlementaires à la rédaction
de ces ordonnances et c'est ce que
semble vouloir accéder le gouvernement
retrait donc a priori nous voterons dans
une très grande majorité de notre groupe
pour cette habilitation pour vous
trouver à les débats sur ce projet de
david assouline ici qu'est ce que vous
trouvez qu'il ya un esprit constructif
dans l'hémicycle côté oui je trouve
d'ailleurs les retrouve les deux
nouveaux députés qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs dans ma france a soumis un
peu moins mais enfin et c'est assez
studieux coup de silence marc rapport à
ce qu'on a pu connaître il ya quelques
quelques années donc à sa volonté
une volonté de d'avoir une attitude
studieuse responsable à la hauteur du
message envoyé par les français
est ce que ça veut dire
couture du pantalon ça veut dire studio
on verra bien ce que sera dans l'avenir
enfin ils ont été ils ont été élus pour
mettre en oeuvre un programme
c'est normal qu'il le mette en oeuvre
reste que je trouve l'ambiance plutôt
studieuse et c'est une bonne chose
en revanche finalement c'est ce cette
habilitation travaillé par ordonnance
permet quand même d'être peut-être moins
sur la technique juridique sur un
amendement plutôt que sur un autre sur
un point de détail qui peut ne pas en
être un d'un d'un texte de loi mais
plutôt sur les grands principes et c'est
assez intéressant donc finalement et
jeudi risque doit combler je pense que
ça permettra peut-être que dans l'avenir
y compris dans le travail de projet de
loi classique on puisse peut-être
travailler davantage en commission une
façon très juridique très technique et
que peut-être qu'on redonne à
l'hémicycle le coeur qui était à
l'époque c'est à dire le coeur des
débats politiques merlus que les débats
juridiques il est tout de même là c'est
le projet de loi d'habilitation
donc c'est la première étape après les
les ordres seront rédigées par le
gouvernement se prononçait pas qu'il
faut s'attendre quand même un peu de
fraudes notamment dans là dans la rue
pour l'instant pas beaucoup les
syndicats va bien c'est la liberté de
manifestation ici mais en tout état de
cause on peut pas dire qu'il ya pas eu
de débat sur les grands principes de
cette loi de l'assouplissement du marché
du travail et de simplification du code
de travail du code du travail et donc
c'est tant mieux que le débat ait lieu
au parlement il peut aussi bien sûr
avoir lieu dans la rue mais ça on verra
bien mais ce qui est certain c'est que
c'était très clairement dit pendant la
campagne électorale par le président de
la république s'est mise en oeuvre nous
franchement à droite et notamment celle
et constructif qui sont de lui des idées
républicains et des indépendants nous
étions tout à fait favorable à ce qu'on
assouplissent le marché du travail qu'on
les libère les énergies de ce pays qu'on
simplifie le fonctionnement et les
échanges au sein de l'entreprise
et bien c'est le cas avec ces grands
principes qui sont édictées à partir du
moment où on est associé à la rédaction
des ordonnances il ya fort à parier que
nous accompagnerons le mouvement le
moment venu c'est à dire au moment de la
ratification et enfin que vous examiniez
ce projet du règne aux senneurs parler
de la moralisation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un sujet qui fait lui aussi un
petit peu polémique c'est vrai notamment
sur la question des emplois familiaux et
de la réserve parlementaire comme vous
l'expliqué quentin calme et c'est l'une
des mesures phare du texte de
moralisation l'interdiction des emplois
familiaux pour les parlementaires
une disposition qui fait écho à la
sphère pénélope fillon
la mesure avait fait consensus en
commission mais mardi soir
coup de théâtre les sénateurs présents
en séance rejette la disposition
c'est genre de texte est insupportable
insupportable de ségrégation
insupportable de reproches
un coup dur pour le gouvernement et le
président de la commission des lois
philippe bach annonce immédiatement une
seconde délibération sur cet article
je considère que le vote que nous avons
eu tout à l'heure revêt un caractère à
certains égards accidentelle
l'interdiction des emplois familiaux est
finalement adopté par les sénateurs en
scrutin public mercredi soir mais ce
rebondissement c'est aussi le signe d'un
ras-le-bol de certains parlementaires
la haute-assemblée vote les dispositions
de la loi de moralisation comme la
modernisation de l'indemnité des frais
de mandat ou encore le renforcement du
contrôle du financement de la vie
politique
mais les sénateurs adresse au passage un
message à l'exécutif
l'état d'esprit dans lequel sont les
partenaires souvent excédés par le fait
que quels que soient les efforts que
nous fassions nous encourons toujours
les mêmes critiques parce que souvent
derrière ce qu'ils avancent pour laver
plus blanc que blanc
il y a une forme d' antiparlementarisme
qui court en fait jusqu'au populisme
avec un point de désaccord entre la
haute assemblée et l'exécutif la banque
de la démocratie rejeté par les
sénateurs qui estime que le projet du
gouvernement restent encore trop floues
l'examen de ce texte c'est aussi le
baptême du feu pour nicole belloubet qui
entre ainsi véritablement dans ses
habits de garde des sceaux vous avez
entendu bruno retailleau que l'on
connaissait bien le sur
antiparlementarisme jusqu au populisme
est ce qu'on va trop loin dans la
transparence
non
il ya effectivement une forme d'
antiparlementarisme faut reconnaître que
certains comportements non cela n'incite
pas avoir une attitude différente
malheureusement donc je suis vraiment
très satisfait que la entre cette loi et
entre les différentes initiatives qui
sont menées conduite notamment à
l'assemblée nationale pour moderniser le
fonctionnement des parlements et de
moderniser le statut des députés et des
sénateurs
on devrait sortir une bonne fois pour
toutes de tout ce qui souvent à tort
aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître laisse
ouvert une porte vers
l'antiparlementarisme
thierry solère récemment parlé
l'immunité parlementaire c'est
exactement la même chose
on sait bien que c'est limité qui a été
octroyée aux députés à la robe remontant
la période de la révolution on pouvait
mettre le la pression même physique sur
les députés pour changer leur vendent ou
changer leur attitude aujourd'hui on
sait bien que c'est pas ça et qu'au
contraire on a le sentiment que ce avec
cette immunité parlementaire qu'on
utilise d'ailleurs jamais puisque les
tout le temps levées que les
parlementaires ont des avantages des
privilèges par rapport aux ouvriers
introduire un abonnement au moment où
vous examinerez ce texte notamment sur
ces thèmes on verra faut qu'on en parle
il faut pas que ce soit le de naissance
ou pas ça donne le sentiment que c'est
un coup matt médias nippons un coup
marketing
mais enlevons nous tout les éléments de
cloutier enlevons nous toutes les épines
du pied qui laisse la porte ouverte à
des attaques contre le travail des
parlementaires qui dans leur très grande
majorité font les choses avec beaucoup
de respect beaucoup d'intégrité et
beaucoup dé ce coup là vous avez le
sentiment que les parlementaires paie un
peu la sphère fiancée je peux lire comme
ça en tout cas les les conséquences de
la sphère filles ont bien évidemment
attendait cette histoire d'emplois
familiaux ne n'aurait pas existé y avait
pas eu cette affaire fillon donc mais
voilà ça c'est la vie c'est comme ça
regardons bien tout ce qui est dans le
cadre des statuts des députés des
sénateurs tous leurs moyens et regardons
ce qui peut être perçu comme logique et
comme illogique moi je suis un fervent
défenseur de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires je pense que c'est une
bonne chose nous sommes trop de
parlementaires dans ce pays pour autant
je suis aussi un fervent défenseur de
davantage de moyens pour les
parlementaires pour qu'ils puissent
faire leur travail en plénitude qu'ils
puissent par exemple avoir davantage de
moyens pour mieux contrôler l'action du
gouvernement qui est une des missions
importantes des parlementaires
aujourd'hui j'ai un assistant
circonscription 1 à 6
à paris on peut pas sérieusement faire
ce travail de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement aux débutants plus de
moyens plus de moyens de collaborateurs
oui pour pouvoir faire un travail en
profondeur
en revanche il faut être moins nombreux
pour pas que ça coûte davantage de
l'argent aux contribuables
et puisque tout ce qui donne encore le
sentiment qui a des passe-droits qui a
pas de transparence qui a des petits
avantages acquis alors même que les
français on demande des efforts aux
français doivent être supprimés la
réserve parlementaire
moi j'ai aucun problème et que ça
puisque c'était en toute transparence
tout ça a été transparent à disposition
du public
mais si c'est considéré encore comme un
avantage acquis on ne supprime pas de
problème simplement ne soyons pas enfin
défendrons avec courage aussi la
nécessité d'avoir davantage de moyens de
travail pour les députés est alors on
dira ce texte moralisation public qui
arrivera donc à l'assemblée le 24
juillet prochain cette semaine aussi
franck riester il ya eu cette bataille
de chiffres à la commission des finances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre gérard n'a malin a accusé le
précédent quinquennat de lui avoir
laissé des comptes dans le rouge
mercredi l'ancien tandem était
auditionné à l'assemblée michel sapin et
christian eckert qui se sont défendus de
toute sincérité budgétaire marion
châtelain une dramatisation de l'actuel
gouvernement sur l'état des comptes
publics
c'est ce qu'a dénoncé hier michel sappin
lors de son audition par la commission
des finances
yat-il 8 milliards de dépenses impayés
j'ai même entendu dire dans la bouche
quand même de quelqu'un d'important 8
milliards de chèques en bois
non c'est faux et la cour des comptes le
démontre quand on dit qu'il ya eu un
dérapage des déficits publics
ça dépasse diktat pourtant fin juin la
cour des comptes avait fait état d'un
dérapage de 4 à 5 milliards d'euros par
rapport au déficit public prévu taxant
ainsi le budget d'un sincère un chiffre
minimisé par l'ancien ministre des
finances 4 milliards 5 d'efforts pour
faire face à des dépenses en cours
d'année c'est exactement dans les pures
habituel d'une bonne gestion de la part
d'un gouvernement qui prend les
décisions qui sont nécessaires en cours
d'année michel sapin se défend d'une
bonne gestion
un avis loin d'être partagé par gérald
darmanin qui dénonce une sous
budgétisation conséquence c'est au
gouvernement de réaliser des économies
cette année la moyenne des mesures
d'économie prises par l'ancien musée
économie des finances michel sapin ses
2.5 milliards
sauf l'année dernière 3 5 milliards donc
on est bien loin des 4,5 et les a prises
en novembre serre qu'il a reporté les
factures en janvier c'est à dire celles
que nous allons payer aujourd'hui une
bataille de chiffres entre l'ancien et
l'actuel gouvernement
mais pour gérald darmanin il faut
trouver 4,5 milliards d'euros pour
rentrer dans ses comptes et contenir le
déficit sous la barre des 3%
voilà trouver 4 5 milliards d'euros
c'est beaucoup
est ce que c'est un budget d'austérité
qui s'annoncent avec des coupes sombres
est ce que vous auriez vous aussi si
vous étiez aux manettes pris ce genre de
décision alors devoir ya deux choses il
ya le budget d'une future du lean 2018
on éduque aller voir des baisses
d'impôts et des baisses de dépenses
il ya la fin du budget 2010 cet essai
les fameux 4 un peu plus de 4 milliards
à trouver
je pense que d'ailleurs dans la
polémique entre les deux ministres c'est
la cour des comptes qui fait office
d'arbitré elle a très clairement dit
qu'il y avait quatre à cinq milliards
d'euros dépasse à de dépassement de
dérive des dépenses et donc et donc du
déficit ou bon ça sert non ça sert pas
observé parce que le gouvernement celui
qui maintenant à prendre les mesures
n'ont pas d'austérité m'échappe rsa de
bonne gestion il faut absolument faire
en sorte qu'on soit 3%
je vous rappelle qu'on n'est pas seul on
est dans un monde ouvert et que à partir
du moment où dans ce monde ouvert la
france doit tenir ses engagements c'est
une question d'image c'est une question
de confiance dans les acteurs consoler
de l'argent au trésor puisque
constructivement mais ça c'est position
d'être constructif franchement c'est une
question d'être un bon gestionnaire de
l'argent public oui il faut absolument
que pour bien gérer l'argent public
tenir les engagements que francs la
france parce que derrière sa peur des
conséquences terribles en termes
d'augmentation des taux le hic
concernant les prêts qu'on a dont on a
besoin pour financer les déficits
il ya quand même des coupes des coupes
en ce week-end à 14 ans la défense la
défense à nouveau gré vers on dit que ça
n'aura pas vraiment d'impact mais quand
même si puisque certains équipements ne
pourront pas être financer correctement
alors alors à court terme manifestement
qui a effectivement 850 millions de
moins
non pas que ce qui avait été prévu à
l'origine mais de ce qu'ils aiment me en
précaution au kazoo c'est un peu gros en
tout cas la conséquence est
qu'effectivement il y aura des
investissements un peu en moins cette
année
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est la
tendance et on verra si la tendance est
suivie d'effet c'est à dire est ce que
oui ou non on arrivera au 2% du pib en
matière de budget de la défense comme
lens et comme s'y est engagé le prix en
arrêt publique le ministre de l'économie
et des finances le mix des comptes
publics l'ont réaffirmé
on verra bien parce que ça c'est très
vigilant fou c'est à dire c'est
l'augmentation sur le temps long des
crédits pour la défense on ne pourra pas
continuer à faire cet effort de défense
et être fort de protection des français
est donc cet effort aussi de rayonnement
du pays en matière diplomatique et
militaire
si on ne donne pas à notre armée les
moyens de travailler correctement non
négligeable
le costume est plus que tendue on a
besoin si on veut pas qu'ils se
déchirent de renforcer sur le temps long
les objets les budgets pour la défense
et ça fait partie typiquement des
critères peuvent nous pour nous
constructif sur lequel on sera très
vigilant alors passé à l'actualité de
votre parti politique républicain frank
riester la question qui se pose est
cette semaine c'était exclure ou pas
vous exclure puisque vous faisiez partie
justement de cette liste de ceux qui ont
aidé ou en tout cas qui soutient
emmanuel macron tel était donc la
question du bureau politique
explications stéphanie des pierres pas
d'exclusion mais les premières sanctions
le premier ministre les trois ministres
lr2 député thierry solère et franck
riester sont suspendus de toutes leurs
fonctions exécutives au sein des
républicains par exemple gérald darmanin
le secrétaire d'état au budget est
suspendu de la présidence de la
fédération du nord
le bureau politique a rappelé que par
leur initiative les membres du
gouvernement comme les initiateurs du
groupe
udi dissidents lr à l'assemblée
nationale s'était placée hors de notre
mouvement
ils ont d'ailleurs déjà été informé
qu'une procédure disciplinaire avait été
ouverte à leur égard après trois heures
de débats houleux les républicains ont
donc décidé de repousser une éventuelle
exclusion des constructif à la fin de
l'été une commission spéciale est créé
elle pourra auditionner les six accusés
pro macron et donnera son verdict hier
soir aucun d'eux n'était présent au
bureau politique ne respecte rien ni
morale dit droit mais nous respectons le
droit donc pour respecter le droit on
respecte nos statuts se trouve que c'est
beaucoup de temps perdu avec des
traîtres
position les rares élus constructif qui
étaient là hier n'interprète pas toutes
de la même façon la création de cette
commission
on a longuement discuté autour d'une
rédaction mais qui est synonyme
évidemment d'exclusion avec la
possibilité de se présenter à une
commission de recours mais bon
globalement c'est plutôt une bonne chose
de se donner du temps c'est pas la peine
d'aller comme mettre au rebut certaines
personnes bruno le maire c'est quelqu'un
de droite c'est quelqu'un de libéral
c'est quelqu'un avec lequel je suis
aligné politiquement il n'est pas devenu
de gauche en allant au gouvernement il
n'est pas devenu un traite il a
simplement envie de mettre son talent au
service de la france au service de
l'économie française hormis thierry
solère et franck riester les autres
députés du groupe constructif à à
l'assemblée ne devrait pas être convoqué
devant la commission spéciale les
républicains leur laisse un temps de
réflexion
ils ont jusqu'à l'automne pour décider
de revenir ou non dans le giron du
groupe l'est républicain classique et
donc du parti créé star voit qu'il ya un
léger sourire
vous avez été convoqué donc vous irez ou
pas devant cette commission spéciale je
pourrais tu es encore convoqué mais non
je ne nommerai pas mais c'est moi j'ai
des comptes à en amis et lecteurs et mes
électeurs ils m'ont demandé simplement
de défendre mes idées
une façon responsable essayer d'avoir
des résultats dans les politiques qui
sont les politiques pour lesquels on
nous attendons où ils attendent des
résultats en matière de jeu de ce fait
aux traits qui m'attire lignes épurées
métier en de sécurité en matière
libération des énergies en matière de
fondation de l'école c'est ça qu'ils
attendraient pas devant cette commission
est ce que ça veut dire que finalement
mais plus rien à faire avec les
républicains ça veut dire simplement
qu'un certain nombre de personnes on les
connaît espèce de groupuscules qui
présente tous les postes qui verrouille
tout les les fonctions pour garder le
pouvoir qui nous ont emmenés dans le mur
en 2012 perdu présidentialiste at-il
dans le mur en 2017 perdre les
présidentielles législatives et qui
continuent à nous emmener dans le mur
n'était 350 députés en 2002 on était 300
2007 200 2012 on est à peine plus de
sens aujourd'hui si on continue comme ça
on sera à pas plus de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le groupe des socialistes on
a besoin de regarder la réalité en face
les français veulent qu'on change de
pratiques qu'on arrête de taper sur les
têtes des gens qui ont un an
donner un avis un peu différent qui
veulent simplement mettre leurs idées au
service du pays
allez vous travailler avant d'être être
travaillée on travaille morano
travailler davantage pour leur pays
plutôt pour leur parti regardez la
situation en un parti politique a perdu
toutes les grandes élections nationales
depuis dix ans qui s'est droitisée à un
niveau en courant exceptionnelle en
courant après front national qui voit
quelques-uns préempter tous les postes
dans les groupes parlementaires et aux
partis et qui est incapable de
travailler de mettre ses talents et ses
idées au service du pays
on a un parti qui a discuté pendant
trois heures de l'éventuelle exclusion
du premier ministre de la france qui est
totale homme de droite qui a des idées
droite et qui les met en oeuvre où on
est on est on est dans une situation
ubuesque mais est ce que ce parti peut
pas dire plutôt que de regarder ma
boutique préparer 2022 programmé petit
poste de se dire j'ai des idées qui sont
les miens qui sont défendues par un
gouvernement dont le chef est un des
membres de ma famille politique et dont
la compagnie est ce que vous y faites
encore mais on vous dit moi je demande
ce que font encore un certain nombre de
ces personnes qui se comporte comme ça
nadine morano moi j'ai effectivement
rien à faire avec ma nadine morano dans
un parti politique elle même qui dit que
la france est un pays de race blanche
pour moi ce n'est pas un pays de race
blanche la france donc la rupture donc
vous voyez là qu'ils ont tiré la
conclusion que j'en tire c'est que la
droite mais il est mieux et le sens tu
mérites mieux qu'un certain nombre
d'individus encore une fois qui par des
manoeuvres qu'on connaît par coeur
réussissent à présenter tous les postes
dans ce parti là et nous en demande de
continuer nous emmener dans le mur c'est
tout ce qu'ils étaient au rouge à la
tribune du trocadéro pour soutenir à
bout de bras françois fillon qui nous en
est lui aussi dans le mur à une défaite
assurée eh ben c'est tout cela qui ont
des comptes à rendre et que nous donne
des leçons aujourd'hui c'est quand même
c'est quand même ça manque pas de sel
alors on a bien compris votre si on va
continuer ce débat avec notre partenaire
du scan qui nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour franck lestage à vous entendre
les ponts ne sont pas complètement
coupée avec la droite vous voulez plutôt
la changer plutôt la quitter est-ce que
c'est envisageable
un candidat constructif au congrès qui
s'annonce chez les républicains
mais vous savez ce que c'est la droite
c'est d'abord des idées c'est des
valeurs et le but de la politique c'est
de les mettre en oeuvre en
responsabilité on a une formidable
opportunité à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat de mettre en oeuvre nos idées
qu'un gouvernement qui dans les grandes
lignes porte c'est idéal pour qu'on les
pourquoi on les met pas en oeuvre pour
quoi on n'accompagne pas ça essayer de
faire battre ce groupuscule dont vous
parlez en votant même il voyait bien que
tout est en train derrière dollar par
exemple allez vous vous voyez bien que
tout est en train d'être verrouillé vous
voyez bien que comme d'habitude on
trouvera les voies et moyens pour
bloquer toute velléité de candidats
tardif je sais j'ai essayé en 2014 j'ai
soutenu bruno le maire pour aller contre
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy parce que
je considérais que de reprendre les
mêmes pour refaire une nouvelle histoire
avec les mêmes acteurs les mêmes
scénarios c'était impossible et qu'on
allait dans le mur je me suis battu à la
primaire pour cela j'ai essayé à un
moment donné de dire peut pas continuer
avec le même candidat on va aller dans
le mur
à chaque fois on a eu un certain nombre
qui ont tout fait et qui ont réussi à
tout bloquer l'on voulait conditions
sont pas réunies donc moi dont je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions d'ailleurs
ne sont pas venus d'ailleurs et valérie
pécresse et xavier bertrand l'ont bien
compris pourquoi ils se présentent pas
alors les ont bien compris tout était
verrouillé dans ce sens ça sera laurent
wauquiez qui sera vraisemblement le
président de notre famille politique
c'est certain mais regardez laurent
wauquiez qui a dit très clairement qu'il
n'appelait pas à voter pour emmanuel
macron entre deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle et cas cautionner le vote
blanc donc na ne s'est pas mobilisée à
cent pour cent pour faire battre la
candidate de l'extrême droite c'est ça
qui cesser ces comportements là qu'on
veut qu aux cieux je n'ai pas essayé de
le battre donc au sein de cette
compétition et on verra bien ce qu'il en
est trèbes verra bien ce qu'il en est
mais je me vois depuis des élections et
des élections commencent à face de
l'autre hypothèse c'est la création d'un
parti notamment avec lui des é
est-ce que ça c'est une hypothèse qui va
se concrétiser d'ici la rentrée par
exemple écouter
- d'abord la première étape qui était
importante pour nous c'était de voir de
quelle manière on pouvait montrer aux
français qu'il y avait à droite des gens
qui voulaient s'intéresser d'abord à eux
plutôt que leur propre parti et donc de
très concrètement mais c'est très
concret ce que je vous dis c'est qu'on a
créé un groupe à l'assemblée nationale
les constructif avec dlr des u10 et des
indépendants pour faire en sorte de
travailler intelligemment de façon libre
responsable avec le gouvernement pour
faire avancer le pays en s'opposant
quand c'est nécessaire mais en tout état
de cause avec un état d'esprit
constructif
demain on verra bien comment les choses
s'organiseront on verra bien parce que
il ya eu quand même trois heures et
demie de débat ça veut dire que les
lettres qu'on a reçus au départ je peux
vous assurer que c'était pour nous
exclure et d'ailleurs bernard accoyer
eric ciotti daniel fasquelle toulon se
répandait en disant qu'on allait être
exclue finalement on voit bien que
commencent à se rendre compte un certain
nombre de personnes que l'on va il va
aller une fois de plus dans le mur si on
laisse les parties dans les mains d'un
certain nombre qui sont toujours les
mêmes est-ce que vous allez vous
rassembler avec lui des i avec les
centristes à la rentrée on parle d'une
université d'été d'un rassemblement des
parlementaires des du groupe construit
c'est une montée ça c'est assez
classique convient qu'on puisse rentrer
entre parlementaires se retrouver à la
rentrée politique confirme la valse ça
tient pas c'est pas décider mais on y
travaille
oui vous avez des informations sera une
très belle destination est d'ailleurs
j'y serai demain pour les commémorations
de ce qui s'est passé il ya un an marine
grenier qui est une des députés de notre
groupe à a posé une question au
gouvernement sur ce sujet et
effectivement il s'est passé des choses
à nice terrible il ya un an gilles ça
fait partie des règles de financement de
la vie politique chaque député doit être
rattaché financièrement un parti ça
rapporte 37000 euros par députés pour le
parti concerné vous même franck restera
quelles parties est vous rattachez
actuellement les républicains les
républicains bien rire
public 1 mais bien évidemment mais bon
ça c'est pas de pourquoi c'est moi
partitionner mon parti politique
d'ailleurs ça me fait assez sourire je
crois si daniel fasquelle qui dit qu'il
fallait qu'on rendre l'argent que le
parti a mis à notre disposition pour la
campagne comme vous l'avez très bien dit
tous les ans on rapporte beaucoup plus
d'argent que ce que le parti investit
sur nous au moment des élections
voilà c'est pendant cinq ans à partir
d'unités de créer un parti pour
justement mais non avoir profité de deux
filets mais non alors il les règles
avaient existé une grande confusion
quand on s'inscrit au moment de sa
candidature à l'élection législative en
préfecture l'argent public reste pour
les cinq ans au parti ya le ciel on est
en revanche chaque année ça change pour
le groupe l'assemblée nationale donne de
l'argent dans les gros groupes
politiques pour fonctionner en fonction
du nombre de députés qui sont affiliés
au groupe et ça ça change tous les ans
très rapidement pour terminer on a
appris dans le canard enchaîné en
l'occurrence que le les députés du
groupe
lr em
n'avez pas le droit de cosigner un
abonnement ou un texte de loi qui était
déposée par un député d'un autre groupe
par exemple le vôtre est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal coûté en tout cas nous
dans notre groupe et constructif les
signatures et les votes sont libres
c'est pas très instructive s'éteint
c'est un grand principe fondateur d'un
groupe
la libye est un vote de l'épée merci
beaucoup merci au père d'avoir été notre
invité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine ni quelles raisons
[Musique]